you do you want to eat the moment you
wake up no i have to force myself to eat
like a peanut butter bagel and that's it
right you know i'm [ __ ] i feel like
we're not designed to eat immediately
when we wake up that's why the biggest
anomaly for me in la is breakfast
burritos dude okay breakfast figures are
good though they're good but also it's
like how they're not breakfast though
yeah right but it's like how do you
[ __ ] eat this much food in the
morning yeah right yeah it's a it's a
it's a lot of food right breakfast like
breakfast burritos is the same way as
the same thing as like a full english or
an american breakfast where you could
like when you have it you just rolled it
they just rolled it off huh they just
rolled they just rolled it up right
they just
yeah i mean i love it i just i could not
eat it ever every day that's like [ __ ]
up yeah that's like two meals yeah great
hangover food though again yeah great
hangover great [ __ ] hangover food
yeah dude i was so hungover after the
credit clash thing i had to move my
flight the next oh i can imagine that
was
yeah there was there was a nice one at
charlie's house oh no i got very people
get very drunk yeah it was nice because
we weren't supposed to drink like before
it yeah yeah yeah yeah i think uh minks
told me that was the hardest thing yeah
she's an alcoholic
i mean i like drinking but i'd be like
[ __ ] i gotta not drink for four months
my boys want to hang out
no drinking and no nutty yeah
like the ultimate challenge
the chicken at least yeah yeah i throw a
bunch of [ __ ] on there okay good then
yeah
okay good i was like [ __ ] if it's just
like grilled chicken yeah no i can't do
that yeah i'd be like [ __ ] i got not
religious about it
but i mean how was living in uh hawaii
because i've never met anyone who's
lived in hawaii it's quite good um very
different than the rest of the united
states were you on the main island the
big island i was not on the big island
so this is the big island which is the
biggest one yeah then there's one called
the wahoo which is the most populated
one so that's like the main one people
good i was on maui which is like kind of
a cross right like there's like lots of
tourism is very nice um but there's also
like a lot of nature so i like living
yeah yeah the nature it's quite nice
there's a lot of weird [ __ ] that
happened there like um stuff that is
normal when you grow up there and then
not normal anywhere else like like what
like um
they're like they're very it's like one
of the most liberal states but they love
guns i love hunting which is cool
um when i would go to school um a couple
of times my pe teacher was like i went
to an outdoor school right like i don't
know school yeah so it's not like an ins
because the weather's you know always
like warm yeah yeah so it's like it's no
it's like it's like multiple buildings
um so it's not just one building it's
like connected by outdoor pathways oh
yeah i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah you made it sound
like the school didn't have a roof no no
it was in the jungle
outdoors
it's like mud huts and everything like
that yeah
yeah it was uh i would go sometimes like
a couple times i'd go do my pe class
and my pe teacher would be like skinning
a [ __ ] fish on the lawn in front of
the class that he had caught that
morning
it was so [ __ ] weird like especially
in retrospect it was like he's skinning
a fish the kids he'd like he'd be like
hey you want fish and he these [ __ ]
like 14 year olds would have a a quart
gallon sized bag of lukewarm fish on the
bus home that i'm just this fat [ __ ]
thing of non-refrigerated fish on the
bus
that muscle like stank up the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah it's a big ass fish yeah some cool
[ __ ] we uh do it one time i was going to
school on the bus
and we saw a deer got hit by a car and
was just dead on the side of the road
yeah and
it was taking the bus home this
dumbass kid from our class had picked it
up and was carrying it back home
he let him get on the bottom like oh no
he wasn't on the bus he was walking so
we saw the kids that were walking if
we're on the bus oh my god he's [ __ ]
he just had it over his shoulders like a
[ __ ] freak like bringing it home to
his family it doesn't sound like the us
like it sounds like it's just part of
the us but yeah it doesn't seem like
it's it's very it's definitely different
from here it's not like it's not like
the boonies or anything like there's
electricity and internet no of course of
course yeah we got houses yeah obviously
yeah the functioning missile system
systems yeah
yeah
um it is just like complete
like very different culture yeah yeah
yeah i mean it must be like quite
refreshing then coming to the mainland
u.s and you're like wow i didn't really
want to leave very bad because it's an
island so right like when you grow up
there you just want to get off it yeah
rich people
yeah we're going to leave
get us the [ __ ] outta here yeah yeah let
me leave yeah that sucks too because
brutus is bad yeah yeah it's not hawaii
it's not even like a tourist yeah
exactly yeah at least like like
waterfalls and stuff we can go to the
beach and drink in the beach super fun
yeah we have um
that's it yeah yeah
we have castles castles and fields yeah
there's like
that's pretty one of the only cool
things it's like you have like so much
history and if you're into that that's
like really cool probably sick for if
you're into history yeah like castles
there was like four castles where i grew
up yeah and that was that is pretty
[ __ ] cool to be fair yeah that was
pretty cool and then like when you leave
like when i actually don't live there
now you really do appreciate you're like
[ __ ] dude it's so cool how much
sheer amount of history you have in
every location
but outside of that you're like well
there's a greg's there in a mcdonald's
yeah
well yeah but at least you guys have
that like you know because there are
like castles in the uk that are easily
like older than the entirety of
australia oh yeah oh yeah so like we
don't have any of that [ __ ] yeah we have
like this building's been around since
the early 1900s and it's like yeah yeah
cool a lot of the castles right where i
grew up were like older like six plus
seven hundred years old yeah right it's
kind of i wish we had that in australia
we don't have any of that [ __ ] yeah we
got dick we just have like it's like
here's a desert it's like you can buy
them you can buy the castles you know a
lot of them are up for sale i've really
i really want to buy a castle but it
just feels like like what am i gonna do
stream the internet's gonna be dog [ __ ]
yeah
i own a castle you know you don't own a
house you don't own property you're in a
[ __ ] castle i saw they were selling
uh a whole like dry moat prison uh
castle yeah oh so there's a moat yeah
that's right yeah so yeah and it was
like kind of it looked like something
from like [ __ ] alcatraz it was like
off the shores as well really cool and
it was uh it had
i loved how they were trying to sell it
they were like it's a very spacious
prison
50
rooms requires uh renovation and like
the pictures were literally just
abandoned
it's like requires renovations to be
[ __ ] torn down and it was going for
like a million pounds so about 1.3
million usd but it was like there's a
[ __ ] moat like
cool you got a moat how are you gonna
get a moat in the u.s yeah that's true i
feel like the moment you say moat i'm
like i'm interested that sounds really
cool did you have to like bring down
like a drawbridge like get people across
or no there was a bridge but the dr
there was a dry moat there as well well
then what's the point in the moment
which kind of kind of thing
yeah yeah i think it must have been
changed or something or i don't know why
yeah damn i really want i would
absolutely buy a castle just for the
flex imagine you're not just a prison a
prison castle a prison castle with a
moat that sounds cool
we can miss the beast please
that's like a missed beast i've bought
every castle in the united kingdom well
you could get a castle in the us just
white castle so i mean it's kind of like
yeah
it's really really different
not the same kind of why would you want
to do that yeah why would you want that
that's really rough that's pretty gross
that is gross you know what i don't
understand in the u.s renaissance fairs
yeah that's kind of interesting as being
like when you're british and you see
those oh you guys don't have those well
then no no that's like that's just
history that's just history for us
i mean you don't you're not living it
you ever been in medieval times
uh no i've been to the pirate one really
yeah that's my friend was like dude i'm
telling you it has the best food in l.a
and so
i've like got my hopes up and it was
like the worst food i've ever had yeah
pirates medieval times and i was like
you think this
is good like the mashed potato tastes
like there's no beans on toast here
[ __ ] all right
american people love mocking british
food because it's funny yeah but your
food is the [ __ ] worst what do you
mean we got like every country is worth
the food you go to the supermarket and
the amount of like ready-to-go meals
that like they would poison you yeah
yeah but i don't eat dogs
because because you're not broke
you're [ __ ] ready to eat meals but
also way nicer like i'd actually eat
them they're actually pretty decent yeah
what ready meals do we have like when
you go sainsbury's you can get those
curries that are like pretty [ __ ]
good they're like two pounds and they're
like really nice like freshly made
card's having a hard time agreeing but
he's tired so his parents
sorry buy the one that's ready to go and
it's like really good stuff like that
like a lot of the ready to go food is
pretty good